[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to this video
in which we are going to talk about
DevOps on AWS so first we will try and
understand what exactly DevOps is all
about then we will see why it is gaining
so much popularity and what are the
benefits of implementing kababs
in your projects and in your company
then we will take a look at where
exactly cloud fits in here and finally
we will see what AWS has to offer when
we talk about DevOps on cloud so first
of all what exactly is DevOps as for the
definition given by Amazon it's a
combination of cultural philosophies
practices and tools that increases an
organization's ability to deliver
applications and services at high
velocity now high velocity is the key
word here because gone the days when it
was ok to release a software upgrade or
any enhancement or a bug fix once in a
quarter today you have companies who are
doing that on a weekly basis and in some
cases on a daily basis so this is speed
actually enables organizations to better
serve their customers and compete more
effectively in the market and once you
have DevOps implemented properly this is
how it looks like you have a delivery
pipeline wherein you are building
testing and releasing your software to
the customers and then you are
monitoring their behavior and planning
for the next release accordingly so what
are the key benefits of implementing and
DevOps in your projects the first and
foremost benefit is better collaboration
among the devs and ops
of your organization so your development
department and your operations
department they work like a single
cohesive unit with little or no friction
which definitely increases overall
productivity of the organization they
was practices such as continuous
integration continuous delivery
infrastructure less code etc make it
possible to release the code very faster
than before with almost no errors
resulting in faster time-to-market and
minimized failed deployments and overall
once you have this shared responsibility
most model as they call it it actually
increases the collaboration release
happens faster which in turn increases
overall productivity of every individual
and the team now state of DevOps report
it's a report published by property law
and Dora which is a diverse research
organization on an annual basis every
year the release this report after doing
a lot of extensive survey of individuals
and companies and based on that they
give you the outcome or the trends which
are going on in the market with regards
to DevOps and some of the key findings
of the last couple of years is if you
implement DevOps you actually gain
frequent deployments you have a faster
empty tier which stands for mean time to
recovery which essentially means that
how much time it takes for you to roll
back if you have any problem coming up
during your deployments in case of a
failed employment rather and yes you
have less number of failed agreements if
you have DevOps implemented properly you
design it in such a way that it fails
less and less you make a deployment
boring in one word
and finally shorter lead times now Liang
is typically a time given to the
deployment team before you tell them
when it has to be released so let's say
it can be 48 hours it can be 72 hours
you have to tell them let's say in one
miga advance so that time gets shorter
and shorter and shorter which means you
can tell your deployment team maybe even
only one hour and once when you are
going to deploy your software and they
should be able to do it that's how it
works so these are some of the key
benefits of implementing DevOps in your
company now let's see how DevOps and
cloud how they are interrelated first of
all there wasn't cloud they are
complementary to each other now most
importantly DevOps and cloud both of
these technologies are comparatively new
in IT industry cloud not so new but
their works definitely it's
comparatively new and important thing to
remember is that both of these
technologies are the ones which are
currently being embraced by most of the
companies they are trying to move
towards jobs and they're trying to
implement cloud in their projects so
what happens is cloud makes it easy to
implement their Web Services because of
inherent abstraction of complexities now
you need not worry about the integration
aspect of your tools and technologies in
particular you don't need to write a lot
of glue codes you just have the tools
and you just have the services you just
and it works absolutely fine and yes you
do get the added advantage of agility
scalability and on-demand availability
to develop services all these things are
inherent when you have a cloud provider
right you need not worry about all these
aspects you don't worry about the
scalability factor of your servers you
don't worry about the on-demand
availability whenever you want a service
you have it available if you are working
on a cloud and yes a combination of
DevOps
and cloud provides a definite advantage
over the competition no doubt about that
so now let's take a look what exactly a
degress has to offer when it comes to
DevOps on AWS now what happens is AWS
happens to call them deployment services
they have a specific services with
regards to DevOps practices they call
them in the comments offices and the
first one is code commit it's a fully
managed source control service that
makes it easy for companies to host
secure and highly scalable tribe it you
get repositories it also eliminates the
need for you to manage your own source
control system or worry about scaling
its infrastructure
you can use it abuse code commit to
store anything from code to binaries it
also supports the
standard functionality of get so it
works seamlessly with your existing lead
based tools you can actually think of
code commit as Amazon's
version of kit lab or github eatables
code pipeline it's a continuous
integration and continuous delivery
service for fast and reliable
application and infrastructure updates
code pipeline builds tests and deploys
your code every time there is a code
change based on the release process
models you define you can easily build
out an end-to-end solution by using
pre-built plug-ins for popular
third-party services like github or
integrating your own custom plugins into
any stage of your list process with a
diverse code pipeline you only pay for
what you use
there is no upfront fees or any kind of
long-term commitments and some of the
key benefits of code pipeline is for
example rapid delivery you have improved
quality of the
all pipeline you can actually automate
your build and test and release process
which actually allows you to easily test
each code change and catch bugs while
they're small and simple to fix you can
assure the quality of an application or
infrastructure code by running each
change through your standardized release
process and you can easily integrate
code pipeline into any other services
within AWS or outside for example you
can pull your source code from github
use your on-premises
Jenkins build server run load tests
using a third-party service or pass on
deployment information to your let's say
custom operations dashboard
next is AWS code variable now a double
scored will actually eliminates the need
to provision manage and scale your own
build service it provides prepackaged
build environments for the most popular
programming languages and build tools
such as Apache maven Dratel add mode you
can also customize build environments in
AWS code build to use your own build
tools into my school build code build
scales automatically to meet peak build
requests and some of the major benefits
of code builds first of all it is a
fully managed service so you know it
eliminates the need to set up patch
update and manage your own build service
it is an on-demand service so you can
use it anytime you want and you pay only
for the number of bills minutes you can
zoom and definitely it is another box so
you don't need to have any kind of
configuration stand it is a free
configure to build environments for the
most popular programming languages all
you need is to point to your builder
scripts to start your first ball now
code deploy is a service that automates
code deployments to any instance
including Amazon ec2 instances and
instances running on-premises if you
need to deploy applications frequently
or to multiple environments or both it
automates the process allowing you to
deploy reliably and rapidly by
eliminating the need for error-prone
manual operations now a double score
deploy helps minimize downtime by
performing rolling updates across your
Amazon ec2 instances and it also tracks
you
application health now cloud formation
actually gives developers and system
administrators an easy way to create and
manage a collection of related AWS
resources provisioning and updating them
in an orderly and predictable fashion it
simplifies provisioning and managing
resources on AWS you can create
templates for these services and
applications you want to build on AWS it
then uses those templates to quickly and
reliably provision the services or
applications which are known as stacks
right and you can wait you can use
various resources such as ec2 VPC RDS
etc as part of your cloud formation
stacks you can provision from a single
ec2 instance to a multi-tiered
application spanning across multiple
availability zones with very complex
routing rules and all this with a click
of a button once you have everything you
know defined properly in the form of
templates in cloud formation either
based opsworks
now this something you can think of as
chef on AWS it's basically a flexible
application management solution with the
automation tools that enable you to
model and control your application and
their supporting infrastructure you can
manage the complete application life
cycle including resource provisioning
configuration management application
deployment software updates monitoring
and access control you can define the
applications architecture and the
specification of each component
including package installation software
configuration and resources so that
actually completes this video and if we
have to summarize with most companies
today adopting both cloud and it evolves
it's even more important to understand
both technologies in right perspective
and how they can complement each other
cloud makes it makes it much easier and
productive to adopt their works
practices on the other hand DevOps makes
the ROI on cloud adoption even more
lucrative for any company dealing with
software delivery so thank you for
watching and see you in the next video
hey once become an expert in cloud
computing then subscribe to simpler
Channel and click here to watch more
such videos turn it up and get certified
in cloud computing click here